the look of love captured on the big
screen and cheering is Selena watch the
South American sex uploading proud
continent from backstage and hanging
with fiance Raj as able kills it with
the 60,000 strong crowd Selena jumped on
board his star boy tour after those very
public dates around Toronto and despite
able unfollowing ex Bella Hadid on
social the hot new power couple have yet
to verbally confirm their new romance
the closest we've gotten so far is this
pre-taped interview with the pit a show
I'm also taking time to have a personal
life so I'm enjoying mixing that because
I've always been kind of straight work
and then in Canada again you know Selena
loves Canadian all right he's not wrong
i mean there was that other high-profile
Canadian guy she dated did we forget his
name anyway as Selena moves on with her
new love unfortunately her fans are
moving to mobbing her at the airport as
she landed in Brazil with Abel perfect
handed outside her hotel and you can
chase them in their car Dom even had to
be pulled off the vehicles by security
and they're not safe from fans indoors
either next after the weekend Argentina
and the north american leg of the tour
that will bring him back home to Canada
mid-april no word yet if the leaner will
be tagging along
[Music]